[Music]
James Comey will begin his testimony
under oath before the Senate
Intelligence Committee in less than an
hour now Republican Jim Risch of Idaho
is one of the 15 senators who will
question him today so here's a look at
the seating chart for this morning's
hearing rich as you can see will be
seated right next to the chairman he's
been a member of the Senate Intelligence
Committee since 2009 and he joins us now
from Capitol Hill senator a big day
today listening doing is no question a
big doin's is right there are reports
that several of your colleagues either
rewrote or revised their questions after
seeing commis opening statements were
you one of those no I hadn't didn't have
any year questions written down before
that but what's your body that was very
I'm sorry go ahead
no you go ahead you go ahead well I
first of all I was glad to get that
seven pages I mean it's clear it's
concise Jim Comey did an excellent job
in putting that together and it's it's
going to make it a lot easier for people
questioning him today so what will be
your focus today what are you mostly
interested in now that you've heard what
he has to say
well obviously I'm interested in the in
him confirming the what he said in the
seven pages I'm sure he's not going to
bury from that really probably in any
way shape or form he's a bright guy he's
he's a person that's highly respected
he's a good lawyer I'm an old prosecutor
he's an old prosecutor that this is not
unfamiliar ground for either of us I've
been through a thousand investigations
while I was prosecutor and charging
decisions so like we're going to try to
get to lay in this thing out for the
American people and I think I think just
seven pages of answered a lot of
questions there were nine reporting in
one-on-one meetings between the
president and his FBI director highly
unusual what questions does that raise
for you well you know first of all this
is an unorthodox presidency so when
things like this happen
I it's the way that the president does
business and certainly
he is not prohibited from meeting with
people who work for him indeed I would
think that most people who have people
working for them particularly their
management team particularly people high
up you'd want to meet with relatively
frequently to talk about things that
that are important so well the Fed
remember I guess what I'm getting in is
the number doesn't bother me
the former FBI director thought it was
unusual and that's why he details that
he started to take memos of each of
those meetings including a dinner that
occurred inside the White House just the
two of them On January 27th and mr.
Comey writes in his letter that this
that he thought that the dinner was at
least in part an effort to have me ask
for my job and create some sort of
patronage relationship would that be
appropriate to have a patronage
relationship between the president and
the FBI director well I don't know what
the I don't I read the conclusion and I
didn't hear all the words were spoken at
the dinner so I don't know how that
conclusion was reached but certainly the
president employs the that position
along with all other positions so again
I think we're going to hear more about
it today and I'm reluctant to either
criticize or defend without hearing more
about it senator if it's all correct in
turn he confirms everything that's in
that opening statement what question
does that raise for you I think more
importantly it doesn't raise the
questions as much as it confirms answers
to questions that I've had I want to
drill down a little bit
on some of those to make sure that I'm
understanding right exactly what he said
thank you thank you senator Risch reject
thank you